c'est leur 4e rassemblement à l'appel du
collectif jaune 78e les lycéens et
étudiants y grimaud a été réunie à
l'université versailles saint quentin ce
matin toujours dans leur ligne de mire
est la loi travail
aujourd'hui on est encore sur l'analyse
que ça satisfait pas du tout la jeunesse
et les préoccupations la jeunesse sont
pas du tout pris en compte dans le cadre
de cette fois donc l'objectif pour
l'instant c'est obtenir un retrait de la
loi travail tant le mot négociation
impossible puisque c'est la base même du
projet de loi qui nous convient pas
c'est l'esprit même de cette loi qui
vise à libéraliser encore un peu plus un
marché du travail qui vise à augmenter
la précarité des jeunes et donc dans
l'esprit même de cette lampe pas
l'accepter le 24 mars dernier myriam el
khomri la ministre du travail a présenté
au conseil des ministres
une nouvelle mouture du projet de loi
pas encore suffisant pour les syndicats
en cette journée de mobilisation
nationale des étudiants ont été rejoints
par les cheminots de versailles
il faut faire absolument la jonction
étudiants lycéens et salariés en grève
quand c'est hyper important c'est la clé
de la réussite pour faire vraiment
vaciller ce gouvernement car il va lui
faire retirer ce texte de loi qui
absolument mortifère pour le pour le
droit du travail mais aussi par année
bien placé nos propres revendications
progrès social les étudiants ont ensuite
rejoint le rassemblement parisien s'il
estime ne pas avoir obtenu satisfaction
ils envisagent de se rassembler à
nouveau le 5 avril prochain date de
l'examen approfondi du texte par la
commission des affaires sociales